hello good evening uh thank you for
having me my name is Alyssa ravazio I
love camping I love camping so much I
created a company to get more people
outside and we've opened access to about
5 million acres of land on this very
beautiful planet we call Earth
um it's a really awesome Planet it has
this really unique ability to sustain
life which is really important to all of
us here and to all of the beans on Earth
and something that I think about all the
time is that our planet's ability to
sustain that life is dropping rapidly
and this is happening on our watch
during our lifetimes
um it's a real tragedy
um this is mostly cause the leading
cause is habitat loss and habitat
destruction which really happen as a
direct result of actions we take
consciously and I think it's just a
really
um yeah tragic Showcase of our cultural
values
however there is a bold beautiful Vision
known as half Earth which I'm sure we're
mostly familiar with here the lake wrote
EO Wilson theorized that if we can set
aside at least one half of the earth we
can sustain life on Earth for a long
time into the future now the main way we
do this is through purchasing land and
purchasing conservation easements on
that land which is really effective at
stopping development but has a major
problem which is that there's no ongoing
system or funding to support the
maintenance and stewardship of that land
this is a big problem even with that
acknowledgment the world is moving
forward here which is exciting last year
at cop15 190 countries signed an
agreement to go for 30 by 2030 the U.S
did not sign but by executive order is
participating this is deputy secretary
of biodiversity Jen Norris that's a real
title and she's leading California which
is leading the world on this we're on
track for 20 five percent already and 30
by 2030. I was invited to participate at
half Earth Day recently and really the
purpose of that discussion was to say
like how are we going to solve this
major challenge of supporting half the
Earth long into the future because half
of the earth is a lot of land and the
future is a really long time
and the perspective I bring to this
conversation is that if you look at the
land today the reality is that most of
it is privately held and especially when
we look at what's public today and
getting to half Earth private land and
the future of those lands is really
where the fate of our biosphere hangs
today and what's interesting is that
this land is owned by people and people
react to incentives and the future of
conservation out of Leopold said it well
is really going to come down to how do
we reward the people who currently have
these lands and this is where outdoor
recreation comes in generally in camping
specifically outdoor recreation creates
a really powerful economic engine that
rewards people who are keeping their
lands open and free and natural fun
places to play I had this experience
personally I went to meet a Rancher a
few years back who'd started hosting
campers and the first thing she did was
hand me this letter and she said you
know I hate this letter they want to buy
my land and build a big hotel but I'm
terrified I'm going to have to call them
except now that I've got camping this is
junk mail I don't need it I know I can
take care of my land these people want
to do the right thing I'm yet to meet
anybody who takes care of the land who
doesn't want to leave it better than
they found it but they need to have the
economic support to do that not only do
people use this income from outdoor
recreation to keep their land they
actually proactively invest it the
majority of people who are earning
income from camping proactively invest
in stewardship think Native species
rewilding restoring stream beds
outdoor recreation also plays a big role
in the solution here by changing culture
another great EO Wilson concept
biophilia we have an innate love for
nature we get outside we can't help but
fall in love with it and we protect what
we love Chris Tompkins said that really
well she also holds a distinct privilege
of being the human who's protected the
most land on Earth at 15 million Acres
which is a lot and so we have to get
more people outside to fall in love with
nature and develop that passion for
protecting it so in summary outdoor
recreation can play a huge role in
solving this challenge that stands
between us and half Earth by developing
sustainable scalable systems that can
support the land economically and create
a culture that continues to encourage
that so I encourage you all to get
outside and next time you're sitting out
enjoying the beauty of our Earth under
the stars please know that you are
contributing to a beautiful future for
our planet in a really positive way
thank you
foreign